Kim kardashian-west addresses reports  that baby number three is on the way I'm  really excited  [Music]  ICI spoke with a 36 year old reality  star at the annual Harper's Bazaar icons  event in New York on Friday where she  played coy over reports that she and  husband Kanye West are expecting their  third child together  via surrogate though Kim wouldn't give  up whether or not North and Saint West  will be getting a new sibling she did  reveal her assets in this stunning  silver sparkling gown while walking the  black carpet during New York Fashion  Week Kim also joked about people  comparing her to Game of Thrones  character Khaleesi with her new blonde  tresses she told reporters quote I love  Khaleesi I've never seen Game of Thrones  but I definitely have to watch  [Music]  Oh